this is adamastor the chief strategy
officer at Mashable I'm here with Gary
Vaynerchuk who is CEO co-founder of
vaynermedia Gary welcome to can
thanks man how are you good so we have
some exciting news together today you
guys are a launch partner for our new
lift lift platform for brand partners
tell us a little bit about why you're
excited about it and how it fits into
what you guys are doing well you're one
of the few people that I think actually
know what they're doing so that that
starts the the interest level at a high
point we're also very focused on the
reality that you know banner ads and pre
rolls are not things we have vaynermedia
or excited about we're not excited about
intrusive advertising we think the
native advertising thing is quite
interesting we think that the demo that
reads your platform your website expands
outside of just industry folk which I
think has a lot of value for the brands
that we represent and so at the end of
the day for us at vaynermedia you know I
come from a retail background so like I
love being a can and I love lions and I
love like awards and information and
you're cool but what I love way more
than that is selling stuff and I think
they you know your media outlet allows
brands to reach actual end consumers at
a scale that a lot of places don't and
to me ultimately that's what kind of
pushed us over to the edge of the
thousands of opportunities we have that
this one made a ton of sense now you're
always talking about content and needs
for brands to create content talk a
little bit about why content is so
important to brands today content has
always been important if you don't know
how to tell your story you lose so
whether it was content at Direct Mail or
on the radio as a pre-roll or as a soap
opera for you know a consumer packaged
goods that invented the genre content
has always been here us youngsters I'd
like to throw myself into youngsters as
youngsters want to make content this new
thing it's an old thing I think what's
happening is that content is finding its
way around being a little bit more into
even instead of necessarily forced down
your throat during a pause and so I
think we're in the golden age of digital
avatar you much more than its content I
mean content is the cost of relevancy in
today
Society we're trying to story tell where
we think the consumer is so for Vayner
it's been a lot about creating micro
content on social networks and then
finding long-form content partners like
you guys and and it's funny even as I
said that I I'm imagining somebody
watching right now and saying Mashable's
long-form blogging is long-form it's but
that's how we think about it we think
the world's fast we think it's a DD and
for us you know this amplification
really matters because at the end of the
day you know we have to rely on the
community that we have on these social
networks to amplify when we can find
partners like yourselves that can give
that extra push off the gate that starts
getting interesting when it's done in a
way that actually is native to the way
people are reading your platform instead
of over here or before I watch the video
that becomes even more interesting so
that's why this fits so well for what
we're excited about